toute sa vie l'acculé une incroyable
collection de tracteurs cette
agriculteur du Loir-et-Cher est
aujourd'hui décédé ses enfants Florent
ont décidé d'organiser une grande vente
aux enchères
entreposés dans un hangar à coude voilà
le trésor ou le fardeau c'est selon qui
a constitué Guy Bourdin pendant des
dizaines d'années certains engins sont
de véritables pièces de collection mais
l'héritage est désormais un peu
encombrant pour les enfants qui
aimeraient s'en séparer si possible à
bon prix Hélène chapelet
il faut le mettre en valeur celui-là
il faut le mettre en valeur ça c'est une
certitude
celui-là je récuré de savoir combien il
va partir niçoise parce que tu vois il
est tout il est tout beau sur les
tracteurs de collection Marc et Étienne
en connaissent un rayon c'est de
nordiste son passage en Loir-et-Cher
pour estimer l'énorme collection qui se
trouve ici
380 tracteurs des années 20 aux années
70 certains sont en état de marche
d'autres nécessiteront quelques
réparations et dans ce dédale quelques
belles pièces comme ce tracteur Porsche
de 1959 c'est une marque qui suscite
beaucoup d'intérêts auprès des
collectionneurs aussi bien de tracteurs
que que d'automobile donc celui-là c'est
un petit modèle s'attracteur qui fait un
peu une petite trentaine de chevaux et
qui a la particularité d'être étroit
donc pour la vigne en fait sa valeur bon
voilà ça dépendra des enchères des
intérêts
suscités mais bon je dirais ça peut on
peut atteindre facilement une dizaine de
milliers d'euros
cette collection c'est celle du père de
Denis guibourdin l'agriculteur est
décédé en janvier dernier pour ses trois
enfants et son épouse impossible de
conserver tous ces tracteurs à masse et
pendant 50 ans d'autant plus qu'il
représente une partie de leurs années de
travail à tous au sein de l'exploitation
familiale
à l'échelle d'une vie de travail de 5
personnes aussi voilà
il y a une partie qui a l'argent de
notre travail qui est là on souhaite que
ça il y a des gens qui ont envie de
qu'on l'amour de la vie mécanique
j'avoue que moi je l'aime un peu moins
la vente aux enchères de toutes ces
vieilles mécaniques aura lieu ce samedi
à coude dès 9h30 plus de 500 lots sont à
acquérir des pièces que les amateurs
peuvent venir découvrir sur site ce
vendredi de 9h à 18h